all of us
at one time or another
find ourselves in a wilderness
we find that we have left familiar
territory
the way ahead is unfamiliar
difficult
uncomfortable
maybe even painful
the wilderness
may be an environmental wilderness
as when mountain climbers are
unexpectedly caught in a
blizzard or when hikers take a wrong
turn and are lost
it may be an emotional wilderness
as when married couples go through a
divorce
or a loved one dies
it may be a psychological wilderness
as when depression descends
or schizophrenia makes itself known
it may be a spiritual wilderness as when
a faithful person suddenly loses faith
or a prayer goes unanswered for a long
time
it may be a medical wilderness as when a
person is diagnosed with a serious
illness
or when a chronic illness takes hold of
a life
it may be a situational wilderness as
when a young adult goes off to college
for the first time
or when someone is laid off and finds
himself jobless
whatever kind of wilderness it is
it is a place and time in which we feel
lost
alone
powerless
the reading from numbers
describes just such a place and time in
the lives of the hebrew people
moses had delivered them from slavery in
egypt and they were journeying in the
wilderness to the promised land
but it was a long
and difficult journey
at times they were thirsty
at times they were hungry
at times they were tired
at times they faced enemies
and at times they were just plain fed up
with the whole
thing that's the way they felt in the
reading for today
they were just plain fed up with it
they turned to their leader moses and
said why why have you brought us out of
egypt to die in the wilderness
for there's no food and there's no water
and we detest this miserable food
in the midst of the challenges of the
journey which were many
they'd forgotten how horrible their
lives were in egypt
they'd forgotten that they were slaves
they'd forgotten that god went to a lot
of trouble to free them
they'd forgotten that moses left a
comfortable life to become their
liberator he was married
he was a shepherd he was
nice it was nice he didn't want to go
all they remembered
is that in egypt they had had food to
eat
and a place to rest their heads
and the truth is
they still had food to eat and a place
to rest their heads in the wilderness
when they had been thirsty god had
provided them with water
when they had been hungry god had
provided food
when they had been tired
god had provided protection
when they had faced enemies
god had defended them
god had met
their
needs
he was even meeting their needs in this
passage he was providing them with food
it just happened to be food they didn't
like
they called it miserable food
well god got a little fed up in return
think of how you felt when you've gone
above and beyond the call of duty to
help someone and no matter what you've
done or how hard you've tried to help it
wasn't enough
the person didn't appreciate your
efforts and continued along their
miserable way complaining
i relate to moses in this passage in my
role as a parent
and i apologize to my children who are
now sitting out there
but there are times
when it seems like i have done
everything i can to take care of my
children and it is still not enough
the food i've prepared isn't the right
food
the clothes i've washed aren't their
favorites
the item i've purchased is the wrong
item
the play dates i've set up aren't enough
play dates
eventually i've gotten fed up with their
complaints and whining and i have read
them the riot act
well i can imagine that that is how god
felt when the hebrew people complained
this time god had had enough
hadn't god been working hard to free
them from slavery and lead them safely
to the promised land
it was time they realized just how good
they had it
so
god sent those poisonous snakes to teach
them a lesson
and once the snakes arrived people
shaped up pretty fast
they went to moses and they said oh we
have sinned by speaking against the lord
and against you pray to the lord to take
away the serpents from us
well of course
moses did as the people asked
god responded by telling moses to make a
poisonous snake and put it on a pole
when a snake bit someone
all the person had to do was look at
that snake made by moses and he or she
would live
now to us in this day and age that
sounds pretty strange
i mean how could that work
but in addition to sounding strange it's
also fascinating
think about it
the thing that in one instance caused
death
in another gave life
the snake could either destroy
or heal it could either kill
or save
what does it mean
for us today
that in one instance a poisonous snake
caused death
and that in another it gave life
in order to explore the meaning of this
dual effect of the poisonous snake we
have to go back to the discussion of
wildernesses with which i opened this
sermon
as i said all of us at one time or
another will find ourselves in a
wilderness of some sort
now wildernesses are difficult
because
they are unfamiliar territory
the coping devices
we've created over the years don't
necessarily work in the wilderness
the wilderness territory may require
different kinds of coping devices ones
we haven't yet developed so we're left
feeling very vulnerable
fears and anxieties that we can manage
in familiar territory become
unmanageable in the wilderness
feeling badly
may lead to behaving badly
as it did with the hebrew people on
their way to the promised land
now these fears and anxieties that
become unmanageable in the wildernesses
of our lives are like the snakes in the
passage from numbers
if we let them get the better of us
they poison us and eventually kill us
now they may not kill us literally but
they may kill us figuratively
they may kill our feelings or our spirit
or our mind
they may make us into the living dead
zombies are very popular now in popular
culture so think of that
they may keep us
in the wilderness forever
but if we don't let them get the better
of us they become the vehicles by which
we are healed
they make us into the living living they
lead us out of the wilderness
now the thing that determined whether
the snakes were agents of death or of
life for the hebrew people was the
nature of their relationship to god
when they turned away from god the snake
was an agent of death
when they turned toward god the snake
was an agent of life
it stands to reason then that the thing
that determines whether our fears and
anxieties are agents of death or of life
for us
is the nature of our relationship to god
when we turn away from god our fears and
anxieties can overtake us
and become agents of death
but when we turn toward god
our fears and anxieties can become the
vehicles by which god heals us
they become agents of life
now you might be wondering
what that would look like
so i'm going to give you an example of
what i mean
some of you might be familiar with the
writings of anne lamott
she's a poet
a novelist and a memoirist
i don't know if that's a real word but
i'm using it
who writes about her spiritual journey
in her book traveling mercies she writes
about the death of her best friend pami
and the deep
dark grief into which it sent her
this is what she wrote about her
struggle with huge and monolithic grief
the more often i cried and felt just
generally wretched
the more often i started to have
occasional moments of utter joy
of feeling aware of each moment shining
for its own momentous sake
don't get me wrong
grief is awful
it really is
unfortunately though avoiding it robs us
of life of the now of a sense of living
spirit
the bad news is that whatever you use to
keep the pain at bay robs you of the
flecks and nuggets of gold that feeling
grief will give you
finally
grief ends up giving you the two best
things
softness
and illumination
a few months before pammy died we read a
line by the great persian mystical poet
rumi
where there is ruin
there is hope for a treasure
anne
devastated by the death of her dearest
friend in the world entered the
wilderness of grief
in that wilderness she discovered the
snake of her fear of grief
had anne given into her fear and refused
to feel the grief that was inside of her
she would have become the living dead
in the process of cutting off her
feeling of grief she would have cut off
all sorts of other feelings
she would have been as if dead
stuck in that wilderness
instead she didn't give in to her fear
she understood that she had to face her
fear and turn toward her grief
just as the hebrew people had had to
turn toward that bronze serpent and
allow god to use it to heal her
and accepted the ruin of her grief
trusting that god was with her in it and
discovered the treasure of softness
and illumination
she just discovered the gift of god's
grace that is ever at work in our lives
even
in the wilderness
now anne's wilderness was grief
but there are all kinds of wildernesses
the point is not what kind of wilderness
it is but what we do when we find
ourselves in one
do we resist the wilderness experience
try to control or manage it so that we
don't have to suffer
or do we surrender to it
and move into it despite the suffering
trusting in the grace and power of god
to get us to the promised land
in other words do we get stuck
for fear of suffering
or do we allow suffering to move us
along
in our spiritual journey
recently i was reminded of this choice
between staying stuck in misery
or journeying to the promised land while
i was having a conversation with my
sister and she's given me permission to
repeat it
here we were talking about spiritual
growth and she shared with me with me
the story of giving birth to her son 28
years before
he's here today
she had taken all of the classes one is
supposed to take before giving birth
class is about what labor will look and
feel like and how to manage the pain
that is of course an inevitable part of
the labor process
so of course while giving birth
she was careful to manage the pain with
all the techniques she had learned
well this went on for about five hours
without the labor progressing
and that's not good
finally the midwife who was attending
her said
do you want to have this baby
and my sister of course said yes
the midwife then said
the next time you have a contraction
find where it hurts
and make it hurt
more
to which my sister replied probably with
some disbelief and indignation you have
got to be kidding i am doing labor
correctly i'm managing the pain and i'm
controlling the situation what do you
mean find where it hurts and make it
hurt more
the midwife having been through this
many times with many women stood her
ground and repeated if you want to have
this baby
find where it hurts
and make it hurt more
well my sister reluctantly followed her
advice
the labor went smoothly and my nephew
was born without complications and sits
here with us today
in the wilderness of labor
my sister was faced with staying stuck
in the misery of the process or moving
deeper into the pain in order to get to
the other side of it
had she decided to stay stuck both she
and my nephew would surely have died
fortunately she made the wise decision
however reluctant of embracing the pain
so that my nephew could be born and she
could live
all of us
at one time or another
will find ourselves in a wilderness
the way ahead will be unfamiliar
difficult
uncomfortable
maybe even painful
along the way
we will encounter serpents of fear
and anxiety
but the very things that create in us
fear and anxiety are the very things
that god will use to heal us and lead us
as we walk along the frightening and
unfamiliar terrain we must remember that
god created resurrection out of
crucifixion
that god could only raise jesus from the
tomb after
he was lifted up on the cross
we must remember that neither death
nor life
nor angels
nor rulers nor things present nor things
to come
nor powers nor height
nor depth
nor anything else in all creation
will be able to separate us from the
love of god in christ jesus our lord
god will not abandon us in our
wildernesses
god will not allow our snakes to
overtake us as long as we lift them up
to him
and allow him to transform them into
agents of healing
and givers of life
amen